UKRAINIAN FORCES.
NIC ROBERTSON HAS A NEVER BEFORE
SEEN LOOK INSIDE SOME OF THESE
WEAPONS.
>> Reporter: AWAY FROM THE
FRONTLINES, TECHNICAL INTEL
OFFICER MAXIM, NOT HIS REAL
NAME, STRIPS DOWN A CAPTURED
RUSSIAN SIGNIFICANCE DRONE.
WE ARE THE FIRST JOURNALISTS
THEY ARE SHOWING HOW RUSSIA IS
USING WESTERN TECH TO KILL
UKRAINIAN TROOPS.
>> THIS CIRCUIT BOARD IS MAYBE
MORE DANGEROUS THAN THE CAMERA.
>> Reporter: THE CELL PHONE
TRACKER, HE SAYS, MADE IN THE
USA.
THE ENGINE, MADE IN JAPAN.
AND THE THERMAL IMAGEER MODULE
WAS MADE IN FRANCE, AFTER RUSSIA
INVADED.
DRONES LIKE THIS ONE ARE A
TERROR ON THE BATTLEFIELD, AND
ARE REVOLUTIONIZING THE WAY WAR
IS BEING FOUGHT.
BUT THE BATTLE OVER CONTROLLER
COMPONENTS INSIDE OF THEM IS
ALMOST AS IMPORTANT AS THE
SUPPLY OF NEW ROCKETS AND
ARTILLERY.
AT THE FRONT LINES, UKRAINIAN
SOLDIERS FEAR RUSSIAN DRONES,
AND CELEBRATE AND SHARE WHAT
THEY CALL SUCCESSFUL HITS.
KYIV'S MILITARY INTELLIGENCE SAY
THE DRONE'S POWERFUL CAMERAS,
WITH THERMAL AND INFRARED
IMAGING, AND CELL PHONE
TRACKING, ARE MAKING IT EASIER
FOR RUSSIA TO KILL UKRAINIAN
SOLDIERS.
>> FROM A UAV OR DRONE
IDENTIFYING A UKRAINIAN TARGET,
IT CAN BE THREE TO FOUR MINUTES
FOR THE RUSSIANS TO ENGAGE THEM.
>> SO FRENCH LENS, JAPANESE
ENGINE, U.S.-MADE GSM PARTS.
SOMEWHAT OTHER COUNTRIES,
COMPONENTS GO IN HERE?
THE LIST, HE SAYS, IS LONG,
INCLUDING AUSTRIA, GERMANY,
TAIWAN, THE NETHERLANDS.
HIS JOB, FOLLOW EVERY SERIAL
NUMBER.
FIND OUT WHO MADE IT, AND TELL
ALLIES TO FIGURE OUT HOW TO STOP
RUSSIA'S DRONE TECHS GETTING
THEIR HANDS ON IT.
BUT STOPPING SUPPLY OF THESE
OFTEN COMMERCIAL COMPONENTS
WON'T BE EASY.
RUSSIA MAY HAVE HUGE STOCKPILES
AND HAS A LONG HISTORY EVADING
CONTROLS.
>> THE FBI HAS BEEN TRACKING
DOWN RUSSIAN SUPPLY NETWORKS
SINCE 2014 AND TRYING TO CLOSE
THEM DOWN.
SO IF THEY CAN CONTINUE TO TRY
TO SIDE STEP IT, AND SIT A REAL
PROBLEM.
>> Reporter: UKRAINIAN
INTELLIGENCE OFFICIALS, THAT
THEY HAVE GONE PUBLIC WITH THEIR
FRUSTRATIONS THAT THEIR ALLY'S
TECH IS ENDING UP